okay we were the serious journalists of
Entertainment News and there we are
dancing in the street yeah
I've blocked this from my memory I don't
remember any of this hello everyone I'm
John Tesh and I'm Mary Hart and I get to
say welcome John Tesh to the show John
and I anchored at the et desk together
for 10 years
one favorite memory his audition from
back in 1986 TV viewers will have the
chance to vote for their favorite song
next week how did that feel I felt
pretty good I mean with your with your
coaching it felt even better well I was
in the flop sweat I was I was really
nervous I really wanted the job you were
very sweet and it was very different for
me so I was yeah I sweated through a
couple of surance shout out to John Tesh
hi I'm John Tesh yeah it's no wonder so
many stars still remember John you know
we built such a beautiful bond which is
why we both got extremely emotional
talking about his new book relentless
john starting
it brought tears to my eyes the first
chapter of your book I had not known
until just before I read the book that
you had gone through this very very
serious battle with cancer
so it truly was life-threatening and if
we can talk about that diagnosis did you
keep that quiet from everybody I did and
I think I think the reason for that was
that I was just afraid of I was afraid
of what what happened to my business our
family business if people were all of a
sudden writing me off because the
diagnosis was dire in my my doctor if he
hadn't found this cancer because it
didn't make a blood markers but if he
hadn't found this cancer the way he did
with the digital exam I wouldn't I just
we wouldn't be having this conversation
and and so I think there's something
wrong John
turned into a trip to UCLA and then to
Johns Hopkins but before that the tests
indicated that I probably had was a very
rare form of prostate cancer and I know
people who are watching this have had
thousands of them had a diagnosis like
this but it's I got by 18 months to two
you know to two years to live they said
they probably guaranteeing me that it
was like pulling the tablecloth out from
your you know foreigner setting and so
immediately you know I wish I was
paralyzed my family was paralyzed except
Connie just immediately she sprang into
action John's wife of nearly 28 years
actress Connie sellecca
along with their children 38 year old
son Gibb and 25 year old daughter prema
provided love and support through the
difficult chemo and surgery but John's
pain and suffering almost became too
much to bear I know there was a point
after the I think it was the first
surgery where you were in such agony you
just you and Connie were holding hands
at your hospital bed and you said please
kill me just kill me
I had complications and they they the
nurse came at me with a with an NG tube
a nasogastric tube and they stick this
tube in your nose because they have to
pump out your stomach and there was
blood pouring from my nose and I was in
so much agony so much pain and we we
looked at we looked at her looked at
each other and and that was that was
exactly what I said because they just I
just I just had enough if they hadn't
been fighting for me I would have taken
the kettlebells in my backyard and
strapped into my ankles and jumped in a
pool I thought about it and then you're
you're crying and you're feeling sorry
for yourself and then you go and you get
chemo and next to you is a kid who has
six more lines in their arms than you do
who's eight years old you know and then
you start feeling guilty so suffering is
real and and I have such respect for it
and for people who get on the other side
of it what did surprise me was that you
really hit that low point and you rode
away on your bike and you essentially
left Connie at home and it almost ended
I started drinking too much scotch
whiskey I was not not available for as
much for Prima and give I felt sorry for
myself and I rode off on a bicycle it
only took about 20 miles and I was
calling Connie asked me how she was
actually I mean and you know she she
ultimately forgave me I used cancer as
an excuse not to fight and that was
wrong even after treatment the cancer
returned it was then that John and
Connie turned to their faith and divine
healing scriptures so instead of
speaking to God about cancer we started
speaking to cancer about God and we
started and we started manifesting that
I would be healed I was healed not only
of cancer and be testing later proved
that but also healed of our terrible
arthritis of my ankle from from all of
the times I'd broken my ankle John says
he's beaten cancer and hopes his journey
can inspire others we have purpose we
have grit we have persistence and then
when you have that all when you mix in
faith filled words you can become
relentless doing anything we love John
and we are so happy
that he is healthy today much more for
Mary and John's conversation tomorrow
how John almost got fired from et can't
wait for that
[Music]